it's Christmas and this year I got
myself a plush tattoo coma and a brand
new Doctor Who Christmas special the
husbands of River Song
overall I like this for the most part
but I am a little bit mixed I do want to
say that for the most part this mood of
this thing was really what I kind of
wanted at this point it's fun it's light
it's a romp given some of the very heavy
stuff we were dealing with over the
course of series 9 especially towards
the tail end you know what I was ready
for something just light fun funny
and remember song is usually good for
that so and I liked her anyway so I was
happy to see her back it was interesting
for the first time having her not
recognize him and I thought that what
that sort of showed about her was
interesting and I suspect some people
probably go how could she not have known
except that she's always known so she's
really just not prepared to even
entertain the idea that she doesn't
recognize him so when she sees someone
she doesn't recognize as the doctor it
wouldn't even occur to her that it might
be him so I kind of like all that the
robot with the switching heads was fun a
little bit goofy but they like just in
the right way they balanced it really
well you know the shouting head in the
bag that was funny
I mean like I said it's a romp it's
light it's fun I was having a good time
and then we got to the tail end of the
thing I didn't lose me but when it got
to the shift of let's let's give a
goodbye to River Song I got a little bit
irritated person because I'm just kind
of sick of goodbyes in general after how
many klar I had and you know we just we
just had a companion exit last episode I
know they could bring her back this is
not to say she may never come back but
this really felt like a send-off and
this is the last time we will see River
Song and I didn't care for that so much
it kind of it put a damper on the light
fun mood which I for one was really
appreciating out of this episode overall
and you know I try not to be too much of
a continuity nitpicker
on Doctor Who especially when it comes
to her song because
good luck figuring that out like the
doctor said we need a bigger flowchart
but there's just certain things about
the way this episode is executed that I
don't like what it means for other
episodes we've already seen now on a
more nitpicky level this does appear to
contradict what we had already seen to
have been implied to have been there
last night together which was a sort of
a little short extra thing I think
series seven maybe six it was extra
stuff it was like little mini episodes
it was never part of a proper episode so
I mean I guess I get wanted to give her
a more proper ending but I'm pretty sure
they contradicted what had already
happened with Matt Smith
but again that's nitpicking I can kind
of just go with that whatever what I
don't like about this whole thing is her
realizing that this will be their last
night together because that doesn't
match the feel and the tone of her in
the very first time that we saw her
which was silence in the library forest
of the Dead because she she never had
the vibe there that she was expecting to
die she was expecting to keep going and
so giving her this ending year where
we're you know she very clearly knows
this is the last time she's going to see
the doctor or or probably will be at any
rate it just just doesn't jive in in a
way for me it sort of takes away from
some of the lovely tragedy of silence in
the library force of the Dead I don't
know maybe I feel a little bit better
about this particular aspect on a second
viewing you know it's happened before it
happened with hell-bent I had to do a
whole other video sort of reassessing
that one but for right now tonight
coming off watching it it was it started
like fun it was exactly what it is
almost kind of a palate cleanser from
the last series not that I didn't like
the last series I liked it very much but
sort of needed just something huh I'm
refreshed and then it sort of ended on
this much more melancholy note which is
normally something that I like it doctor
but just something about the way that it
was done this time didn't quite work for
me overall though still a good episode
still had fun excited for when we will
new Doctor Who which will not be for
months and months and months and months
and it'll be a long wait but don't worry
I'm still gonna have some Doctor Who
content going up intermittently I still
haven't gotten up my list of favorite
eleventh Doctor's stories so that is
coming I promise I I'm not gonna give a
date cuz if I give it I'll miss it but
it'll be up soon you know we're getting
into a new year and I'm probably gonna
start plugging stuff more at the end of
the so please like subscribe you can
find me on Twitter at Council of geeks I
have a podcast the council of geeks
podcasts on iTunes and stitcher and did
you see the husbands of River Song if
you did what did you think about it drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned